the nigerian-based insurgency boko haram
has widened its attacks into neighboring
countries one village in northern
cameroon is now taking matters into its
own hands by setting up a vigilante
group to protect families two's blaise
aeong traveled to dubli just a dozen
kilometers from the nigerian border
we are on our way to northern cameroon a
region under persistent threat from boko
haram we've been granted rare access to
the area by vigilante group
it's a routine daytime patrol in the
village of dubli
these vigilante members are checking
everyone entering the village even
people they want to prevent boko haram
militants from attacking their village
these men are taking no chances
the terror group has intensified attacks
in cameroon since the end of last year
they go after farmers and behead them in
their own farmlands
people are killed for no reason they
kill grandfathers grandmothers just
anyone even young people
they trouble us a lot and when we meet
them we have no pity for them
boko haram has killed thousands of
civilians soldiers and vigilante members
in the nearby town of mora a senior
government official isn't willing to
comment on the vigilante activities
he says the army is determined to push
back boko around
day and night our security and defense
forces are on alert
that is why they are on the field
and they are doing
the results can be seen
not even one inch of our territory has
been occupied by the enemy and none will
be occupied by boko haram
but the vigilantes have already caught
insurgents and suicide bombers sent by
boko haram
and this village has a history with boko
haram
when the islamists first attack cameroon
in 2014 and 2015 they killed dozens here
this time the village vigilantes are
determined to stop that from happening
again
[Music]
i do this work for the sake of my
village and for my parents my younger
brothers my children and my mother
i do it for the entire village
around 120 men take turns working
12-hour shifts
but they are fighting with limited
resources and without any pay
there are fewer job opportunities in
cameroon's northern regions
poverty and lack of work is stressing
the stability of the vigilante groups
some young people say they may not be
able to continue protecting their
villages
we are the ones protecting our village
we look after the security of our
village yet we don't even have enough to
eat
there are no jobs and there is nothing
that brings in earnings
trying to make ends meet while working
to secure the village just won't
work for now the group is on waving
keeping watch
they have little faith that the army
will be able to protect them
so they have to make sure everyone is
safe
while dw's blaze aeong files that report
and he joins me now so blaise how
widespread are these attacks by
insurgents in cameroon's north
ataxia
they are widespread boko haram started
its attack in cameroon in 2014 burning
down villages schools and government
infrastructures kidnapping people
beheading civilians but since december
2020 rights group says that attacks from
the
from boko haram have have multiplied and
especially since the dead of uh
the former leader abu bakr shakal when
we were in the region uh security forces
told us that boko haram has changed its
tactic that they no longer attack
civilians as much as they used to do
before now they are attacking cams
uh hosting uh security forces and and
according to uh government officials
and also security sources they say boko
haram is trying to win the population
over to them and then
by attacking
security forces
your report mentioned that security
forces are on high alert so what more
are authorities doing right now to
combat this terrorist threat
what i'm saying is that i i think the
cameroonian authorities are not doing
anything different from
what they were doing in 2014 when boko
haram began its attacking cameroonian
territory they have deployed the
military they have
mounted posts across
the far north region but that is just
the region is still very poor and a lot
of analysts believe that the reason why
boko haram has a strong grip in
cameron's extreme nod is because of
poverty is because people there do not
have a better uh source of livelihood as
we've seen in our report and they are
easy recruit for uh boko haram
activities so the government is
practically doing doing uh more
more or more of a uh trying to fight the
insurgent with with soldiers but on the
ground people are still very poor and
this is easy for boko haram to recruit
new members
and the violence in the country's north
has displaced many people what more can
you tell us about that situation
yes the violence in extreme law has
displaced a lot of people and we must
know that it's not just
attacks from boko haram that has
displaced people there's also uh
in inter-ethnic violence in in in former
cameroon a couple of weeks ago two
tribes
have been fighting uh because of water
and people fear that boko haram could
come in and empower these two try to
fight among themselves and then to
create a
more chaos in in the region and also the
problem is a lot of people invested in
ammunitions they bought guns they bought
other weapons to protect themselves from
boko haram and when there is a conflict
between two tribes these tribes now come
together and fight and kill themselves
which makes the situation which was
already worse i mean
it just
the problem even more yeah it's a very
dire situation dw's blaise ayong thank
you very much
you